[Musica]
[Applauso]
da piccolo guardavo sempre le formiche
anche adesso è non è che abbia smesso
però passavo tante ore a guardarne il
movimento sui ramoscelli nell'erba e
pensavo che fossero casuali che si
muovessero a tastoni che si muovessero
in maniera totalmente disordinata poi
crescendo in realtà ho capito che non è
così che le operaie ciascuno operaia in
realtà lasciano una scia odorosa per
farsi seguire dalle altre e che quindi
il loro movimento non è per nulla
casuale certe cose che ci sembrano
casuali in natura
in realtà sono regolate da leggi ben
precise
mentre certe cose che ci sembrano
ordinate sono frutto del caso
guardate per esempio questa immagine è
un totale intrico di robbie di ombre e
di luci dure del mezzogiorno ma in
realtà in questa immagine
c'è qualcosa che voglio farvi vedere e
che magari i più attenti di voi avranno
notato non si vede vero questo è un
serpente e io vi ho in qualche modo
disegnato il serpente con il giallo ma
non si vede ancora bene perché perché il
ruolo del fotografo naturalista in
realtà è quello di andare a magnificare
a rendere più manifesto anche a chi non
è del settore un animale o una pianta un
fungo un fiore qualcosa che magari
bisogna andare a cercare in posti
completamente caotici completamente
intricati e allora con la macchina
fotografica
questi animali emergono con tutta la
loro magnetica bellezza e diventano più
manifesti a chi sta guardando anche
sott'acqua è così perché anche
sott'acqua il mediterraneo sembra che ci
sia un deserto gli scogli e ricoperti di
alghe sembrano delle macerie quasi vuote
prive di vita ma poi quando vai in
immersione con la maschera e la macchina
fotografica riesci a isolare dei piccoli
tasselli
di vita ea portarli a chi magari non ha
la possibilità di andare sott'acqua e di
vedere la manifesta intelligenza del
polpo per esempio ecco che però in
realtà i fotografi spesso si concentrano
solo sulle specie più carismatiche le
specie più belle più famose più popolari
ma realtà dovrebbero forse cercare di
fotografare anche le specie più comuni
la prospettiva delle zampe di un
gabbiano su una scogliera durante una
giornata di tempesta sul mare oppure in
quest'altro caso io stavo guidando
l'auto e ho visto i riflessi della città
nella superficie del lago e c'erano
delle comunissime anatre e germani reali
che in qualche modo galleggiavano perché
ormai era sera è il mio occhio mi ha
suggerito di accostare la macchina
fermarmi e fotografare quel tassello di
ordine che emergeva in mezzo al caos del
traffico mentre stavo guidando insomma
il ruolo del fotografo è un po quello di
isolare degli elementi ordinati
all'interno di un mondo che continua a
muoversi un po come un'anatra ferma
immobile in mezzo a decine di altre
frenetiche questo in realtà è una cosa
che noi sappiamo perché già il nostro
cervello agisce un po da filtro nei
confronti del caos che ci circonda
venne fatto un esperimento nel 67 sul
movimento degli occhi degli spettatori
che stanno guardando una foto di un
volto è quello che si è visto è che
appunto gli occhi dell'osservatore
percorrono un percorso ben preciso cioè
si concentrano sugli occhi il naso e la
bocca dell'immagine che stanno guardando
che dal punto di vista evolutivo ha un
senso perché quelle sono le sedi
dell'espressività quindi capire che
intenzioni ha la persona che hai davanti
può avere effettivamente un senso quindi
anche una cosa che ci sembra così
casuale come il movimento degli occhi su
un foglio su una fotografia in realtà
non è affatto casuale
i fotografi lavorano un po così perché
se riuscisse in realtà a quegli schemi
si troverebbe un certo disagio come in
questa immagine che invece un
elaborazione al computer noi lavoriamo
con degli schemi che sono pre impostati
in qualche modo è una cosa assolutamente
interessante che in natura ci sono
questi schemi ea un occhio attento
possono apparire e quindi quando te ne
vai con la maschera e dentro un lago nel
caos più totale
emergono le ninfee che sinuose sembrano
precipitare verso il fondo oppure se te
ne vai in montagna per esempio troverai
magari una volpe
ma non solo la volpe ci sarà per esempio
una serie di una ripetizione seriale di
elementi verticali dietro che sono
quegli alberi quei larici che sono un po
come le colonne di un di un cielo oppure
durante una nevicata in inverno un
maschio di muflone in tutta la sua
bellezza con le corna ricoperte di neve
e di ghiaccio si manifesta in maniera
perfettamente simmetrica questi sono
tutti schemi sono tutte cose
preimpostate che noi abbiamo anche nella
testa che andiamo a ricercare come
fotografi in natura
durante una giornata di pioggia una
salamandra pezzata che si muove con la
sua pelle umida nel sottobosco
in realtà e inscrivibile all'interno di
una spirale tutte queste fotografie è
così ordinate in realtà un attimo prima
un attimo dopo sarebbero state più
disordinate sarebbero state diverse
sarebbero state qualcosa di meno preciso
di meno perfetto dal punto di vista
della geometria se vogliamo
le fotografie sono delle schegge di
ordine in mezzo al caos
questo è il fatto e a volte però la
scelta giusta non è quella di cercare
dell'ordine per esempio nelle foto di
nebbia come quella che vedete in questo
caso di caprioli siamo molto attirati da
questa condizione che però non ha
geometri
i particolari perché anche qui abbiamo
un retaggio evolutivo cosa ci sarà
dietro la nebbia ci sarà qualche
pericolo ci sarà qualche predatore ecco
questo è il motivo per cui siamo
attirati dalle foto con la nebbia una
volta era proprio questione di
sopravvivenza mentre adesso ovviamente
questo interesse si trasforma in un
interesse di tipo estetico
e a proposito di predatori anche se meno
pericolosi per noi il lupo la storia del
lupo in italia ci insegna come in natura
ci sia una serie di collegamenti e di
reti e di causa effetto che a volte ci
sfuggono a volte non sono così immediate
non sono così manifeste per esempio
l'uomo popolo alla montagna e il lupo
scompare o quasi
l'uomo abbandona la montagna e il lupo
ritorna ci sono tantissimi di questi
fenomeni a cascata anche negli animali
più piccoli
pensate per esempio ai ragni i ragni
predano su tutto il pianeta ogni anno
tra 400 e 800 milioni di tonnellate di
insetti inclusi quelli dannosi per le
colture o per la salute umana
pensate a quanto caotico sarebbe il
nostro mondo senza anche l'aiuto delle
loro ordinate ragnatele
ma una cosa che a cui spesso si pensa
ultimamente di cui spesso si parla
ultimamente è l'avanzata della natura in
ambiente urbano la natura che come un
bicchiere d'acqua rovesciato su un
foglio per capillarità penetra nel
tessuto delle case delle strade dei
giardini e quindi in maniera anche un po
ingombrante all'interno delle città si
ritrovano caprioli cinghiali cervi volpi
e questa è un po l'emblema del caos che
avanza in un film avrebbero detto che la
natura non la puoi contenere a volte
dolorosamente si ribella non la puoi
tenere rinchiusa e non la puoi neanche
tenere al di fuori di queste nostre
città così
riordinate tra virgolette ed è così
quindi che in un vicolo
magari una sera ritrovi un orso che è
l'emblema del selvaggio
anzi del selvatico più che altro e credo
che i fotografi non debbano concentrarsi
solo sul fotografare cose molto belle
i fiori la bellezza della natura
eccetera ma devono fotografare anche i
problemi e non solo i fotografi tutti
dovremmo anche occuparci dei problemi e
della conservazione della natura
pensate per esempio che nell'ultima
pulizia di spiaggia che ho organizzato
c'erano più pezzi di plastica che
granelli di sabbia è stato veramente
toccante perché tu puliti un metro
quadro di spiaggia poi ti spostavi nel
metro quadro accanto e nel camminare
spostava i granelli di sabbia nel pezzo
che sembrava pulito emergeva altra
plastica è una cosa veramente
incredibile quella mattina non ero da
solo c'erano varie persone con me
abbiamo raccolto 500 kg di plastica e ce
ne sarebbe stata ancora tantissima e ora
io dico che è probabilmente un'utopia
pensare che ci possano essere spiagge
con solo uova di razza come questa o
conchiglie o granelli di sabbia
però questo non ci deve assolutamente
scoraggiare dal fare qualcosa in prima
persona da cercare di mettere ordine nel
caos che stiamo facendo anche noi perché
in fondo
l'uomo è parte della natura e il futuro
e anche nelle nostre mani
grazie
[Applauso]